Short and sweet number 14. We said that based on everything we learned, we did not understand why is the common custom that wine poured by a Muslim or an irreligious Jew is prohibited to drink.
The confusion mainly stems from the fact that we said that if one of the four criteria are missing, and the person who poured the wine was a non-idol worshipping individual, such as a Muslim or an irreligious Jew,
So because of the concept of Nachas Dargah, of going down one level, the wine should be permissible to benefit and to drink from.
So Rav Ovadya gave us one approach, and he said that, at least in the context of the Shulchan Aruch,
the Shulchan Aruch, he says, really holds that be'etzem, really inherently,
wine which is poured by an idol worshiper is prohibited both to drink and to benefit from.
And therefore, even if you're missing the criteria of shaking,
We saw from the Ashkenazic postgame, Rav Moshe Feinstein, Rav Shulchan Aruch, Rav Ovadya Yosef, they all said that the minug is that wine poured by religious Jews and Muslims is still forbidden to drink.
We had a couple of different reasons. Possibly number one is that we're Mach Melech Tataz, the pouring still would be prohibited, even if the person is not an idol worshiper.
The second one is that deliberate pouring is considered shaking, and there's no way to really get around that.
If the wine was deliberately poured, that's considered shaking, and you could have all four requirements to prohibit the wine.
We also had Rav Shulman Zalman Orbach who told us that when the wine is poured by a Muslim, even the wine which is remaining in the bottle is forbidden.
And Rav Yosef said that even when it was poured by an irreligious Jew, the wine which is remaining in the bottle is forbidden.
We had two different ways of understanding Rav Yosef.
The first one was that although we do say Nachas Dargah to allow the wine, that's in benefit.
So that we said that's only in a situation where you had non-Jews.
The whole concept of Nachas Daigah was only applied to non-Jews, but irreligious Jews never had this concept of Nachas Daigah applied, and therefore the remaining bottle in the white would be forbidden.
Another reason to explain Rav Ovadya Yosef is that he can hold that pouring is considered shaking, like we mentioned before, and therefore we view it as if they did shake the bottle, and the wine inside the bottle is forbidden for that reason as well.
We did say that because of all the factors that we've learned to this point, and another possible consideration of Kavod HaBrios,
that if a person would have an irreligious Jew pour them non-mimitial wine, and by not drinking it, it will cause them to be embarrassed.
And again, a Kavod HaBrios issue.
So then there is possible room to be lenient and to drink the wine that was poured.
However, if they won't be embarrassed, the best thing is to avoid it.
The minik is not to drink it and to get around not drinking that wine.
We mentioned the question of clinking glasses with a non-Jew.
So we said, for many reasons, if a person would clink their glass with a non-Jew,
even if the Jewish person's glass had non-mubushel wine in it, the wine would stay permitted.
First of all, we said the movement of the wine when you clink the glasses is not really considered shaking.
It's just a slight movement.
The second of all is, even if you want to say it's shaking,
but since it's the Jewish person's movement and the non-Jews together,
We said that when a non-Jew and a Jew pour wine together, the wine is permissible, and certainly when they just clink the glasses together.
We said that if, let's say, a non-Jew accidentally touched non-Mavushal wine, so based on what we learned in the past already,
if the person was a Muslim, it would be permitted to drink.
If they're a Christian, it would be subject to the Mahalokas between the Shulchan Aruch and the Ramah.
The Shulchan Aruch would say it's forbidden to drink, but you can allow it to get benefit from it, and the Ramah would say it's permitted to drink.
And the question of drinking non-militant wine on an LL flight, it was very much not recommended.
If it was being poured by an irreligious flight attendant, there are those who allow it.
However, we said it would not be recommended to do so.